welcome
today we are going to take a look at
forms of energy such as kinetic
electrical thermal gravitational
potential energy
it turns out when you start thinking
about energy on smaller scales or the
microscopic level
all of these forms of energy are
basically two things
one kinetic energy particles moving
around and two potential energy energy
stored by a field such as electric
magnetic or gravitational
let's start with a deceivingly simple
example and explore properties of energy
as we zoom in
i'm drawing a glass of water
this water has a temperature
i can warm up the water by adding energy
from an electric stove
or cool down the water by putting it in
the fridge thus removing energy in the
liquid water
from this example we can see that
temperature is related to energy
but how is it related to kinetic or
potential energy
this big picture the macroscopic scale
allows us to look at energy in terms of
temperature but let's go to the
microscopic or small scale to get a
better picture of the physics at play
as we look inside this liquid we see
lots of water molecules moving around
zoom zoom zoom
well they don't actually make a sound
the average speed at which these
molecules move is related to their
kinetic energy and its temperature this
is thermal motion
if we zoom in again
we can look into the strong chemical
bonds within molecules
here the individual atoms in this case
for water is hydrogen and oxygen
they can vibrate back and forth and
rotate so they also have kinetic energy
let's look at another example between
macro and micro scale energy
interactions
when you burn something think of a fire
a chemical reaction takes place and it
releases a lot of energy how does it do
that
let's look at the microscopic scale to
find out in this example i'm going to
burn methane gas and the chemical
reaction that takes place is methane ch4
and oxygen o2
they rearrange to create water h2o and
carbon dioxide co2 plus energy
before the reaction there is a greater
chemical potential energy than
afterwards but don't worry energy is
still conserved because that potential
energy is converted to kinetic energy
and radiation
what is the source of chemical potential
energy
at this level we can think of individual
bonds between atoms storing energy so
that energy can be absorbed or released
as bonds are broken and reformed
but where does the energy in chemical
bonds come from we need to zoom in again
in a single atom there's a nucleus that
contains protons and neutrons
and overall has a positive charge
this creates an electromagnetic field
the interaction of other charged
particles like negatively charged
electrons relatively far away from the
nucleus
with this field provide potential energy
you can think of this electric potential
energy as the same kind of concept as
the potential energy of a mass in a
gravitational field
zooming back out each molecule has its
own particular configuration of charged
particles within the electromagnetic
fields
right
this means it has an associated
potential energy
as we've seen this chemical potential
energy is the result of energy stored in
fields
okay so we've covered electrical
chemical thermal types of energy but
there's other forms out there right
for instance what about sound waves
here's a speaker
and an ear
the energy in sound waves is transferred
through the vibrations a back and forth
motion of molecules in the air
another example could be
elastic potential energy or the energy
stored in a spring at the microscopic
level as you stretch the spring see the
hand stretching the spring the atoms are
being pulled out of their equilibrium
position within a solid and thus gain
potential energy from the
electromagnetic force that holds the
solid together
how neat is this we can describe all
these energies
as just kinetic or potential
so there's one more microscopic form of
energy that we need to talk about and it
might seem a little complicated at first
let's go back to the combustion example
we talked about earlier
as i said before this process releases
radiant energy
we can see burning objects that glow
brightly we can also put our hand near
the burning object don't touch it and
feel the radiant heat
this radiation that's emitted carries
energy with it
so how do we explain the radiant energy
does it fit into one of these two
categories either kinetic or potential
energy that we've been discussing
well
it turns out it sort of fits into both
groups whoa
electromagnetic radiation such as light
can be modeled in a couple of different
ways which we'll go into more detail in
another video but one way to model the
light is as a wave of electric and
magnetic fields
another way to think about light
is being made up of particles called
photons in this instance the particles
are carrying the energy so with both of
these models radiant energy can be
explained by the same microscopic
interactions that cause the other forms
of energy
in conclusion we can see energy at the
macroscopic scale like temperature or
light being emitted however we must look
at the micro scale to observe the
different forms of energy that we
experience are really just the result of
kinetic and potential energy of
particles
how cool